[Music]
you are releasing a rap album I am
releasing a rap out it's a comedy rap
album okay let's you know it's it's
called the morning-after pill which is a
play on my name life in times of the
homie Steve now the homie Steve is my
rap name because it's so thugged-out you
know it's so gangster from the streets
of Brentwood right well J did his dirt
so I had the idea that I will parody
certain rappers and create an entire
album based around it and one of the
songs when the singles from the album a
buddy of mine Jason Hightower and I
wrote called summer dreams so the
premise is my my white manager shows up
Bernie Bernstein and he shows up to my
door to tell me that I'm going broke all
right I said well why am I gonna broken
he says well you live this extravagant
lifestyle what do you expect and I say
well how can I fix this problem and he
says well just simply incorporate a
product into one of your songs and then
you'll make all kinds of money which is
what a lot of rappers do my character
decides to put all the products in his
songs and in doing so you know it's a
summer song it's about barbecues and
having fun in love but when he does this
what ends up happening is he
incorporates all kinds of products and
eventually it gets out of hand so the
song is pretty much just a bunch of
products can we hear a sample of it we
have a microphone right there I just
want to get a sample of what this is
like oh yeah I need a hype man with me
so if anybody wants to light them up
Andy you wanna yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah look sexy when you do it so summer
dreams summers are hanging out in the
couch here we go all right music
[Music]
it's the summertime can you feel it I'm
trying to make your mind baby is your
with it it's the summertime can you feel
it it's just being you baby let's go get
it Dove soap and Snapple enhance away
BVDs and some receive fresh like good
days they do your figure he'll figure
Kraft cheese macaroni click eat a banana
I still Meyer baloney Campbell Soup
Cream of Chicken with stars target JC
Penney Sears coals in Marshall's I'm a
bad boy and that's word to Chex Mix
disrespect I still your Pepsi while
streaming my Netflix I got through your
rhymes like get an incision UBS's dude
around in my house they be Berle vision
[Applause]
you just made a lot of money
[Music]
you